[Music]
i pay a lot of attention to what's going
on in environmental
sustainability in most of the places
that we live if you reflect back 10 or
15 years the climate literally is
changing
and i believe that my kids when they're
adults and when they're actually at a
point in their career where they can
make a difference
it will be too late to have made a
difference
for ryan popple business is personal
regardless of where you work i think
you've got to be asking
tough questions about what are we going
to do to actually solve this problem
the co-founder and executive director of
ev startup proterra
is determined to usher in the age of
clean energy
the technologies are now largely in
place to solve the climate crisis
and for his part he's focused his
crosshairs on a sometimes
overlooked contributor of carbon
emissions
[Music]
buses
[Music]
buses and freight trucks combined
comprise about 30 percent of the world's
carbon emissions from the transportation
sector
replacing internal combustion buses with
e-busses
is well in the works and electric buses
are poised to take over
half the world's bus fleet by 2025 but
there's
one problem almost all of them are in
china
as of 2019 china had already amassed a
fleet of over 420
000 electric buses europe was at just
over 2 000.
the united states about 600. today
electric buses make up less than 0.1
percent of america's public
transportation fleet
so now we've got to ask ourselves well
if china was able to get it done
and eliminate 200 000 barrels of oil
per day by switching their bus fleets to
electric then we ought to be able to get
it done as well
the problem though is that we will not
see the political will
or consensus in the united states or
europe
to quickly move away from fossil fuels
to
clean technology the good news is that
while diesel buses have been getting
more expensive three to four percent per
year
electric buses keep getting cheaper and
they keep getting better and they're a
much better user experience
we want to win using market forces and
be completely independent of whichever
way that political winds are blowing
[Music]
after college i served in the in the us
army and that's really
what transformed my view around energy
security
just seeing how volatile some parts of
the world are in particular parts
that we're very much dependent on for um
for fuel production or petroleum supply
every day the world needs about 100
million barrels of oil
and so that is absolutely an
unsustainable situation
the answer to energy security is going
to be finding alternatives to petroleum
it's not going to be trying to produce
more petroleum
after his tour of duty ryan went to
business school and landed himself a job
at tesla in its early years
[Music]
my reason for being at tesla was not
because i was a sports car enthusiast it
was because of the
cleantech aspect of what tesla did you
cannot solve the congestion problem
simply by making cars cleaner
a big piece of the sustainability story
around proterra
is the benefit of mass transit this was
a way to get clean
ev technology into the absolute
mass market right now and not wait for
electric cars to be cheap enough for
everyone in the economy to afford them
today ryan heads the charge for zero
emission battery electric buses in north
america manufacturing its own vehicles
in facilities in california and south
carolina proterra has sold over 900
electric buses to transit agencies
throughout the us and canada
based on the promise of lower operating
costs and less noise and pollution than
diesel buses
the company says its city bus can go
about 350 miles on a single charge
over twice the distance of an average
city buses daily mileage
throughout the ev world the best
products are going to be those products
that were purpose built and designed
from scratch to be an electric vehicle
we make our own chargers we make our own
battery modules we make our own packs
we vertically integrate into any
technology where we find that the
the existing supply chain isn't good
enough for where we're trying to go from
a performance basis
to make the cost benefit more attractive
to local deficit hawks
proterra has innovated a battery leasing
program
allowing cities to go electric at the
same price point as a standard diesel
when you buy a diesel bus you don't pay
up front for
12 years of diesel fuel that would be
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
capital expenditure
so what we do is we break the battery
out of the cost of the vehicle
and then they pay for the battery over
time like it was the fuel
and that's enabled a lot of cities that
might not necessarily have the capital
to make the switch
to be able to do so now proterra is
already moving beyond city buses
to electrify other types of large
vehicles they've recently begun
delivering electric school buses with
their partner
thomas built buses the company has
secured over 500 million dollars in
private investment to date
much of it from automakers which seems
to vindicate ryan's pro-business
approach
to sustainability technologically
we are at the moment where we can start
really scaling clean energy
solar wind energy storage energy
efficiency electric vehicles
charging stations these are the high
growth industries of the 21st century
if investors can make better returns
investing in clean energy technology
then it really doesn't matter whether or
not you convince anyone that it's the
right thing to do or the wrong thing to
[Music]
do
you